Omar, how you doing? Yeah, I'm doing
good, man. How about you? Welcome.
Welcome. Was that guy? Was he listening
to that? Oh, yeah. Was he a real Muslim?
Um, maybe he's unaware of his creed. I'm
I'm assuming he's Sunday. He was jama,
but I I can like make like a definitive
case based off of that alone. Okay.
Well, he he was saying that Jesus is the
that Jesus is going to judge on judgment
day, raise the dead, all that kind of
stuff. I think what he's trying to
articulate is that when the text of the
New Testament uses like the term Jesus,
the begotten son of God, he he's trying
to put for that's using in like a
metaphorical sense. Whatever that sense
may be, I'm not aware of. He's not here
to defend that position. What about
Jesus raising the dead and judging at
the last hour? You think that that's
Islamic Islamic? I would say no. Okay.
What about Jesus being the begotten son
in a metaphorical sense? Is that Islam?
Yeah. Where does where does the biblical
text articulate that he's the only
begotten son of God? That's John 3:16.
John, what does the Greek word use there
for begotten? Just one second. I I asked
you specifically. Is that Islamic? Is
that Islamic? No, you can't you can't
say that he's the only begotten son of
God. So then you can judge if he was a
Muslim or not, right? I would say I
would have to understand what he means
by this. Again, I'm not here to claim he
wasn't. Okay, hold on. Relax. No, I'm
trying to say that given this alone, I'm
not going to talk fear him off of a
conversation alone. I you talk to him.
So somebody can there is maybe some way
some way, shape or that someone can
affirm that Jesus is the begotten son of
God in some sense, the begotten son of
Allah in some sense uh maybe not literal
but in some metaphorical sense he's the
begotten son of Allah and still be a
Muslim. You can't talk fear him for
that. the under the what I'm trying to
articulate is that I'm not my job is not
to give like a or on it. I say whoever
affirms the literal sense and even the
metaphorical sense. Whoever affirms this
because Quran explicitly talks against
this. The Quran articulates
in Right. We agree. But yeah. Um I just
have a question. Oh, I I I had that
question for you. I was going to ask if
you agree with him that Jesus was a
Muslim. I believe Jesus was a Muslim.
Not based on the biblical text. Not
based on the biblical text. No. In the
biblical text, is Jesus a Muslim? I do
not believe the totality of the New
Testament would articulate Jesus to be a
Muslim. So when we look at the New
Testament as a whole and we look at the
person of Jesus, he's not a Muslim. No,
cuz it articulates him with
christologology with somewhat
highristologology given the text. So you
only have Jesus being a Muslim or this
Issa character being a Muslim in the
Quran. Uh yeah, I see no issue with
that. Cool. Cool. So Jesus was not a
Muslim historically just it's just a
religious claim. Well that's
presupposing that the New Testament work
particularly the synoptics and John are
accounting for reliable historical data
on the man named Jesus Christ or Jesus
of Nazareth. What language did he speak?
I don't know that's irrelevant. You know
it is relevant. It's not relevant. It's
very it's very relevant. What language
did he speak? I don't know what language
he spoke. I don't see the relevancy
here. Where was he born? I don't know
where he was born. Nice. So you don't
know the language he spoke. You don't
know the the where he was born. How did
he pray? How do you pray? We pray. No,
not you. How did he pray? How did he
pray? I have no like basis given with
the data I have that he in a specific
manner. So you have nothing about how he
prayed and his language, his birth, who
are his disciples. Um his disciples we
don't specifically in the Quran it
doesn't mention I believe it doesn't
mention particular names. M um based on
that I can't necessarily give you
specific names. Okay. So you don't know
his disciples. How many disciples did he
have? Disciples of the Quran. I do not
recall if they do give a number of how
many? It doesn't. It doesn't. Okay. Then
then it does. You don't know his
language. You don't know how he prayed.
Did he fast?
Um I would say off the Quran. Uh no. I
don't I don't see any evidence of Quran.
So you don't know if he fasted. You
don't know how he prayed. You don't know
the language he spoke. You don't know
where he was born. You don't know who
his disciples were. You don't know how
many disciples he had. Where did he
preach? Uh he preached to the people of
Beni Israel. Where Ben is? Yeah. Do you
know Do you know who the people of um
Yeah. Where were they? They were they
were I believe they were located in
modern day Palestine. How do you know
that? Where do you get that from? based
on the maps given based on like what we
know geographically. Yeah. What is that
based off? I wasn't done yet. If you
want to I'm just going to keep it honest
with you. I didn't come here to discuss
that point in particular. I'm I can
literally grant to you that this may be
the case and we do not have any data
based on Jesus through other documents
and and even the Quran. You're not going
to grant the Quran that we do not have
any let's say relevant documentation
contemporary to this man name Jesus
Christ. I can grant you that. So you
don't have any historical evidence that
Jesus was an actual Muslim. You don't
have anything objective. The Quran The
Quran is The Quran is The Quran is not
evidence. The Quran is making the claim.
The Quran, if you're going to grant to
me my paradigm, if you're going to look
at a whole paradigm, we have to look at
the paradigm in totality. All the Oh,
yes, we do. What do you mean? I'm not
granting you your paradigm. What I'm
granting you is the claim. I know that
the Quran makes a claim. I'm not
granting it's true. I'm not grant I
don't I don't care about how Islam
reasons with that. It makes the claim
that he's a Muslim. Okay. But with no
substance, correct? It's just a claim in
the Quran and you believe the Quran for
whatever reasons you believe the Quran.
Right. Sure. We can grant that. Okay. So
you have nothing. So again, you don't
have an objective standard, historical
standard on Jesus being a Muslim or not.
It's just a claim. Like an objective
standard for classifying people to be
Muslims. there be I didn't offer a set
of sufficient conditions onto which
you're able to establish such a
proposition. You didn't ask for an
objective metric by which I'm able to
use this. All you asked was uh it was
like 20 questions. It was like uh okay
what language did he speak? Where did he
preach? Um etc etc. All of which I'm
being honest here. I'm trying to be
genuine here. Just mentioning off 20
questions me not being able to answer
with the Quran does not actually prove
your like view at all. It just proves
that we don't have data. and said it
again. It proves what? It just proves
you don't have any contemporary data
proposing. You don't have any data on
Jesus. So if you don't have any data on
Jesus, how the hell can you say that
he's a Muslim when you have no data?
Okay. For instance, the Quran again I'm
like okay. So if listen in my paradigm
you have to look at it from different
perspectives. You do this in religious
studies, you do this with any branch of
theology. You look at it through the
perspective of the interlocator or
another position. How old are you, if
you don't mind me asking? If you mind,
then you don't have to. Yeah, sure.
Yeah, sure. I'm 15. You're 15? Yeah, of
course. Wow. So, you're still in high
school? Yeah. What about it? Huh? Yeah.
What about it? I'm I'm just amazed, man.
It's pretty cool. I wasn't doing that.
So just for reference, your conception
of who this figure was and who you
believe this man was is based on
unreliable
documents based on a text that you
cannot actually trace back to Jesus. And
not only that, the conception you put
forth of God is contradictory. Wait, so
you're saying that what I have, the text
that I have is not the angel that was
given to Jesus. The inje literally
cannot be and again it cannot be this um
the four-fold gospels. I'll even grant
you a four gospel on the basis of this
was given to Christ. Was it was he given
a physical book? No, we believe it was
like a Sharia. It was a like more or
less it was somewhat of a message. So,
right. So, he was going around orally
preaching this in June. Yeah. It's
called the good news. Okay. And it got
written down eventually, right? Uh, I
can grant you it's been written down. I
can grant you that somebody that's been
written down by by who? By who? I'm not
going to grant you who it was written
by. You don't I'm not asking you to
grant me anything. I'm asking you just
simple question. Who is the jail written
by? I don't know. Okay. You don't know?
Well, if you had to give an educated
guess, who do you think like would have
been the people writing the jail? If I
had to guess, maybe scribes that heard
this, it could have been maybe even the
disciples. I can even go as far to grant
you that. But again, I think this is
shifting the goalpost. I don't think
it's shifting anything. I think you're
right. I think you're right on the go.
Point is, I mentioned Wait, hold on a
second. Hold on a second. Notice why
we're here. We're here because you said
that what I'm what this idea that I have
of Jesus comes from in unauthentic, you
know, sources. You know, these sources I
have, these texts that I have is
unauthentic, right? And so you're saying
that this is not the ine that the
Christians had and that Jesus was
revealed and was preaching around.
That's that's why we're here. This is
important. We're right on the goalpost.
And so when you say allow me to explain
how you shifted it. I I didn't I didn't
shift any. I'm right on what we've been
talking about this whole time. I just I
think we're actually right on the cusp
of realizing something important. Just
like we realize how you had no data on
Jesus. Okay. Okay. We're realizing that
you also have no data on the NGIL. Like
you uh we do have data. You have data on
the NGI. So what I consider to be data
would be information given by let's say
subject X. Subject X gives us that this
was a a kab given to Issa. Well, yeah.
So again, when you say it's a kab given
to Jesus or given to Issa, what was
that? What was that?
The angel. What is it? Well, yeah. What
was it? The kab or the in jail is
considered to be the good news. What was
it? It was the good news. What was that
good news? The good news was about the
Can you show me this? Like, can you How
do you know? Let me pull it up for you.
Okay. In the Quran. Got to go through my
notes. It's all right. Take your time.
I'm uh I'm going to read a couple super
chats as you get that. Okay. All right.
All right. We got uh let's see here. Uh
saw those. Saw those. What is the best
Bible translation? I mean, I personally
use ESV.
Um, also NASB is pretty solid, too. Um,
not there's nothing perfect, but I
personally like ESV. It's the one I use.
Let's see. Grace Unfolded says, "Love
the ex-Muslims episode, and you should
do it once a month to encourage others
sitting on the fence." 100% agree with
that. Chlory says, "Super, oh, just sent
a super sticker." Thank you so much. We
got Patriotic Z says, "Say Allah is one
of and best of
creators." Interesting there. Patriotic
Z Lynch sent it. And Omar, cut in
whenever you're ready. Yeah, sure. Yeah,
sure. I would say I did like um say
something false. I I will correct
myself. What the Quran explicitly states
is that it specifically uh contains
guidance and light. Okay. What guidance
and what what was that guidance and what
was that light? What does light mean?
I'll pull up a tap sear for you. I don't
care. No. What? A tough sear? Yeah. What
do you mean? But the taps will be
getting their information from the Quran
and Sunna, right? Oh, yeah. Yeah. So, I
need from the Quran and Sunna what that
guidance and light specifically is.
Yeah, sure. I'll send you a that
mentions I don't think like a taps ought
to be structured in this manner. Taps
are based off a Quran and Sunnah, but
they're also based off the understanding
of the said individual um giving a
commentary on the said Quran. Yeah. From
the Quran and the Sunna, right? Yeah.
It's also hinged upon the person. Okay.
So they're understanding what they have
seen in the Quran and the Sunnah and
they're making commentary on it or
giving their opinions on what they on
what they understand. So that's why I'm
asking when you say what when you're say
you have data on what this is. Mhm. I
haven't gotten anything just yet. What
is this guidance? What is this light?
What was it? It was written down but you
don't know by who. You know scribes
could have been the disciples. We don't
know. Um, was it written in the time of
Jesus or was it written maybe after he
ascended to heaven? Uh, we can't make uh
we can't make a premise on that. Okay.
So, we don't know when it was written
necessarily, but sometime after Jesus.
Yeah. Um, not that's not a necessary
truth. Oh, like Oh, so it could have
been written while Jesus was walking
around, which is true, right? It could
have been written while Jesus was
walking around preaching. Yeah. It's um
Yeah. Meaning like for instance, like we
wouldn't say that it is it ought to be
written after or ought to be. It could
it could have been written after. It
could have been written while he's
around, you know, preaching and stuff.
Fair enough. Okay, fair enough. So, we
don't know who we don't know exactly
when it was written or who wrote it. We
don't know exactly what was in it. Um,
so how do you know that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John didn't write this in you?
How do you know so given the manuscripts
we have on these four texts? It is
there's no evidence to suggest that the
texts are given to Christ. There's no
evidence to suggest that. Pause that.
Pause. Pause. Because remember again, we
we already settled that Christ wasn't
given texts at all. Right. You're right.
But the message that he preached ended
up being becoming texts. So how do you
know that Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
didn't write these texts? Why would I?
Okay. So I granted you previously for a
separate point that it could have been
written down as a text. And I granted
you previously for a separate point. I'm
willing to grant it now. I just want No,
it definitely was written as a text.
Sure. We'll grant. Yeah, sure. Whatever.
So, the text specifically states with
all the manuscript evidence that these
people particularly were not disciples
nor associates with this man named
Jesus. All right. Wait, pause. You're
saying the Quran says that the people
who wrote the Injil were not associated
with Jesus. No, I'm saying with given
the evidence on these texts, meaning
these four gospels, there's no evidence
to suggest that these authors have any
ties to this man. Oh, got it. Okay. How
do you know that the that the writers of
the Injio had ties to Jesus? Why is that
relevant? Because you're saying that the
Injil is not the the the Injil is not
the text that we have because boom,
because of what you just said. that the
authors of the text that we have of the
New Testament gospel um they don't have
any association with Jesus. So therefore
that would be assuming that the NGL was
written by people who had an association
with Jesus and so therefore what we have
can't be the so how do you know the was
written by people who associated with
Jesus? Yeah, let's say this, right? If
we're let's say transmitting a or
tradition and the person is writing it
down, he had have he has had like he
would have to have heard this or
tradition. Correct. Sure. And these
authors there's no evidence to suggest
that they've heard of this or tradition
known as the good news. There's no
evidence to suggest and that you're
making there's no evidence to suggest
that these authors have heard of this
thing called injil that's actually
mentioned in the Quran. Well, wait. I'm
I'm confused. When you say that there's
no evidence that these authors ever
heard of the Injio, how how do you know
that the authors of the NGO heard of the
NGO? No issue. They would have if you're
going to say that they was written down
was written down. They would have have
to at least heard of this thing called
the angel. Got it. This this good news.
And do the authors of the New Testament
claim to be writing down the good news,
the gospel? They claim to. Okay. So then
that is an an evidence pointing to them
hearing about this gospel, right? It
doesn't intend that they heard the
contents. Well, I I'm not saying that,
but they heard of something called the
gospel, right? We can grant that for the
sake. Okay. So then there is evidence
that they heard of a gospel and they're
writing down this go they're claiming to
write down this gospel that they heard
of. How do you know that that what
they're writing isn't being cuz it
doesn't align. It doesn't confirm the
Torah. We can go say that again. It
doesn't confirm the Torah. It doesn't
confirm the Torah. Yeah. The Gospels
don't confirm the Torah. It Wait, just
be just to be clear. How do you know
that the Injil confirmed the Torah
specifically according to the Quran? No.
No. How do how do you know that the
Injil confirms the Torah? Like
objectively. Yeah. Cuz the Quran says it
does. What do you mean? That's that's
that's a that's circular. That's
circular reasoning. Like Okay. So, for
examp let's if if that's your reasoning
though, that's fine. Let's go with that.
The Quran says that the angel confirmed
the Torah. So therefore, the angel can
confirm the Torah. According to the New
Testament Gospels, do they confirm the
Torah? according to they make the
affirmation but they don't actually
confirm. Okay. Boom. So they make do you
see that? Notice what we're doing here.
We're working together. They make the
affirm. They make the claim that they
confirm the Torah. Now you would argue
that they really don't. But that's not
what our our argument is. It's the claim
cuz according to the Quran or you the
Quran's claim was good enough for you.
The Quran claiming that the NGO confirms
the Torah was good enough for you. Okay.
Well, these authors then these texts
claim to confirm the Torah. So
therefore, it looks like we're it's
checking off the boxes of requirements
that you're that you're issuing to claim
to confirm the Torah. They do that. To
claim that they've or have some evidence
that they've heard of some gospel, we
see that. So these it looks like they're
matching up what you would think in jail
to be. So with the conditions I
outlined, if you wanted further
clarification on specifically I think
the second one where I said they would
at least have to heard of the ine or of
the good news. I am more particularly in
this instance referring to the contents
of it. Oh nice. I think it's further
clarification. They would have to like
like I'm sorry but like it was I'm
referring to the contents of the
subtext. That that's fine. But so there
so like for example Mark says he starts
off the his writing saying this this is
the gospel of Jesus Christ the son of
God and then begins to write the gospel
of Jesus. Yeah. Yeah. Like but like at
the end of the day this is saying the
author is Mark. I don't grant the author
as Mark. I I'm not regardless whatever I
don't it doesn't matter. The the Mark
here is claiming to have written the go
writing the gospel of Jesus. Right. At
least according to that document, it's
claiming to contain the contents of the
gospel of Jesus. Right. It's contain
it's making the claim that it has it's
the beginning of it. That's what they
right. So it's not not just the
beginning of it. It's it starts off with
the beginning of the gospel of Jesus and
then proceeds to tell the gospel. Right.
According to its its claim, right? Okay.
Sure. I like I think like this document
is claiming this document is claiming to
have heard of or to be aware of the
contents of the gospel of Jesus and
proceeds to write it down. How do you
know that he's not writing the jail? No
issue. The author, again, I don't know
why you kind of brushed over this. The
author of this text is claiming to write
down this and its contents, correct?
Yep. Okay. the contents specifically
what the Quran is outlining. I'm I'm
going to use the Quran here. He Allah
says in surah 5 ayah 46 it contains
guidance and light guidance and light we
agree and according to our paradigm
again this is a internal critique and if
you want to bridge it off to a
metacaritique that's a different thing.
The critique is it's confirming this
these four texts. Correct. It's
confirming the the four-fold gospel.
Correct. Yeah. Okay. If it does not
contain guidance and truth and it does
not confirm the Torah actually doesn't
then is not the ine by the criterion.
Okay. So containing guidance and and
truth. Yeah. um and confirming the
Torah, right? So that means that you
need to know what that guidance and that
truth was in the NGO to judge that
what's being written in the document
that Mark or Matthew or Luke or John
wrote that this guidance and light isn't
the guidance and light that was in the
NGO. Right. Yeah. Sure. So how do you
know that the guidance and light that's
written about in Matthew, Mark, Luke and
John is not the guidance and light in
the NGO? So the guidance or I think it's
referred to asan here it's simply it
means the gospel directs to other people
towards belief in God in righteous
behavior and moral living from my
understanding on the verse and then nor
would be symbolically refers to clarity
and truth and wisdom. We we know what we
know what guidance and light you don't
have to do that we know what I'm
breaking it down for I'm breaking I'm
breaking down. We have to We have to
break it down.
Stop. I am cutting you off cuz I got to
get you back on track. I don't need
that. Neither does the audience need
that. The only thing we need is for you
to answer directly. How do you know that
the guidance and light being written
about in Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
and truth? It says truth, too. Yeah.
Yeah. For example, John John chapter
one. Watch what it says here. John,
you're talking about You're talking
about guidance and light. Watch this.
That's true. Yep. Watch this. You're
talking about guidance and light. John
1, a matter of fact, let me put on the
screen for us all. I know, right? John
1. In the beginning was the word, and
the word was with God, and the word was
God. He was in the beginning with God.
All things were made through him, and
without him was not anything made that
was made. In him was life, and the life
was the light of men. The light shines
in the darkness, and the darkness has
not overcome it. Right? Boom. Boom.
There was a man uh sent from John, you
know, to bear witness about the light.
So in this gospel, we got guided. We got
some light here. And right here, verse
nine, the true light, which gives light
to everyone. So that's talking about
guidance, right? Was coming into the
world. He was in the world and the world
was made through him. Yet the world did
not know him. He came to his own and his
people did not receive him. But to all
who did receive him, who believed in his
name, he gave right to become children
of God, who were born not of blood, nor
of the will of of the flesh, nor of the
will of man, but of God. So this is this
is truth, right? Guidance, light, truth.
All of this is talking about this
guidance to back to God, worship to God
and truth of God. All of what is No, no
issue. The So how do you know that this
isn't this isn't in the Okay, no issue.
The Quran according to us is the truth.
That is the truth. The angel, hold on,
relax. The Quran, the angel simply
contains the truth. The truth, the hook
is not this idea of
polytheism. And all these I forgot to
read you one more verse. I'm sorry. The
word became flesh and dwelt among us.
I'm aware of this. Wait, wait, no. But,
but hold on. Just to meet your criteria
here. And the word became flesh and
dwelt among us. And we have seen his
glory. The glory of the only son from
the father full of grace and truth. It
looks like John is matching the exact
criteria that you talked about.
Guidance, light, and truth. What we
doing here? Mere man claims about what
is to be the truth. Not necessarily
until for it to correspond with reality.
Nice. Again with regards to this point
about John 11, John 114, etc., etc. I'm
I'm fully aware of this. I can grant you
this portrays whatever notion you wanted
to portray on Christ. Guidance, light,
and truth. Guidance, light, and truth.
Right. Author makes the claim that is
proclaiming guidance, light, and truth.
It's it's do we agree that correlation,
the mere claims of such do not entail
causation to refer to the text? There we
go. Nice. So that's why we are back at
the question. How do you know that the
truth, guidance, and light that's
mentioned in the gospel of Matthew,
Mark, Luke of Jesus according to
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John is not the
guidance of light in this in you're
referring to? How do you know? And this
like a weird way to put like that. I
don't like the connotation you put with
that. Why not? Answer your question. I'm
going to answer your question. So with
regards to how do we know it's not
referring to this text the hook the hook
the truth apied from the fact that it
was genuine revelation from God it's not
man-made or fabricated this is
fabricated and
man my brother you are not helping me
that you did not answer my question you
you presume that this is fabricated fine
that doesn't help I'm able to establish
how it's fabricated well well you're
you're going to be in trouble. Then how
do you know that this guidance, truth,
and light that's mentioned in what we
just read in Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John is not in the jail you're referring
to. No issue. The text contradicts the
Quran at pivotal moments. Right. And
secondly, I I know I know you've like
you've you've been through this round a
lot. So that's why I'm trying to be like
more like somewhat trying to be upfront
with it. Unique a little bit a little
different. You are you've you've given
me a fresh kind of take here like you're
you're you know you've been different
which I appreciate. So So if it's a true
message from God and it's illuminating
the teachings of God. Uhhuh. It was it
was it means to rightly guide its
followers. Wait, wait, wait. Rightly
guide its followers to what? To
monotheism. to the hook. Well, we that
that's fine. We've already seen that. My
point my question, how is it my brother
Okay,
this is like you're not I I I know that
this cuz this is this is my third
favorite uh subject. My first favorite
is the Quran confirms the Bible. Second
is Jesus being a Muslim. And my third
one is what is the NGO? Because with And
and let me give you this too. You're
pretty smart. I I think it's the first.
It's like those you kind of equivocated
one and three. They're do the same
thing. Uh, not really.
It's a different angle. I guess it's a
different angle on one. It's a different
angle on one. Okay. So, the thing is is
that with this question, we're dealing
with an existential question on what the
gospel, what the angil is. You guys say
we don't have it, which assumes you know
what it is. You have to know what it is
to know what it's not. But you can't you
can't you can't tell me true. Well well
it well it is because you can't even
tell me what you can't tell me what this
is. You can't even give me reasons for
why this is not the you can't you
haven't been able to do it just yet.
We've been stuck on the same question
now. How do you know that the guidance
truth and light mentioned here in the
gospel is not in the you say because it
goes against the Quran. That's like,
yeah, it's clear. So, it going against
the Quran means that it's not the Injil.
Yeah. How do you know that the Quran is
in line with the Injil? Because the
Quran is the word of God. That's not
That's another You're begging the
question, bro. How do you know? Have
Have you seen the Injil? No. You ever
read it? Uh, no. You ever touched it? I
don't think so. You ever smelt it? I
don't think so. You ever tasted it? I
don't think so. You ever felt it in the
atmosphere? Like, you know, you just
felt like its power level? Uh, I don't
think so. You never seen it, touched it,
felt its power level, tasted it? Oh,
man. Yeah, I was about to give you
points, man. You don't know. Just Just
bypass that. It's all right. Forget
that. But all of these things, you've
never experienced the angel in any way,
shape, or form. Yeah, we still we still
there's still criterion that's outlined
within the text. What's the that it has
to contain the hook? The
norm. I'm sorry. I I'm cut The reason
why I'm cutting off because I wanted you
to repeat what you said first. All in
all, your real criterion, your real
criterion is that it has to line up with
the Quran. All that other fluff,
guidance, and light and truth that you
was talking about, fluff. We got to the
core issue. The core issue is is that it
has to line up with the Quran. That's
what it is. And so because Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John does not line up
with the Quran, that's why you say
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John is not the
NGO. That's the only reason. No, there's
there's many different aspects until
you're able to establish. No, that
you're ignoring when I mention the Huck
the when I mention this, this is what
the contained. This is what it contained
or contains even the I'm still I'm still
wondering how you know that the
guidance, light, and truth that we read
about is not the NGO. Give me something
there. Since it's not, oh, it just
doesn't agree with the Quran. Give me
something, right? It contradicts the
Quran. Boom. That's all you got. That's
all you got. You don't have nothing
objective. I don't have nothing
objective. Okay. So, what would Okay.
The this idea of an objective metric,
this objective conditions that I laid
out. Yeah. I laid out that it has to
contain light, guidance, and truth. And
we saw that we saw that it does, right?
It doesn't line up with the Quran
doesn't fulfill the criteria. Claims and
making claims about I contain light,
guidance, truth does not actually entail
for you to contain light, guide, and
truth. Where do you get this from? Where
do you get this from? That in order for
the angel to be the angel, it has to
line up with the Quran. Where do you get
this from? Yeah, it's logical. Where do
you get that from? Logic. Logic. Yeah.
Go to 1094 for me in your Quran. I'm
about first to like go to Muhammad if
you're in doubt about their previous
stories. Nice. Yes. We're about to rip
the I'm about to snatch the red carpet
from under your feet. Oh, really? Yeah.
Interesting. According to that text now,
let's just Can you read Can you quote it
again so that everybody can hear it? Um,
if you're in doubt the previous stories
or sometimes like some translator or
like interpretive translate as like
revelation, uh, go uh go to the uh the
previous people. I think man, you
butchered that. This is what the text
says. Okay, it says, "If you are in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you, then go and ask those who have
been reading the scripture before you.
Be not of those who doubt. Truly, the
truth has come to you from your Lord." I
kind of switched those sentences, but
you get the idea. Yeah, I got sure. All
right. So, if Muhammad is in doubt about
the Quran, the revelations that he's
that's given in the Quran. Now let's
grant that it's talking specifically
about the stories mentioned in the
previous scriptures. Let's let's grant
that for Muhammad to know that the Quran
is getting these things right. Where
does he have to go? Uh he would have to
go to the previous uh scripture. So what
is the authority on what is true or
false? Is it the Quran in this text
context or is it the previous
scriptures? The previous stories in
scripture I think I translate it as
stories. Me personally the literally
stories is not in the verse. Are you
sure? Yes, it's revelation, bro. You
know, I'll pull it up for you.
Translation, let me pull up the word.
Maybe I'm wrong. You're going to learn
to trust me, man. Come on, man. So, if
you are in doubt concerning what we have
revealed, an unzala, let me I'm trying
to pull up on my end. So, I'm going to
look at your screen. I got it over here
on the right.
Uh, let me pull it up my Let me pull up
that tab. Hold on. Oh, this one. What is
this? Oh, is this corpus or what is
this? This is a corpus. So it breaks
down the word for word. Uh let me pull I
want to cuz I do I use a website also
similar to this. It's um Corpus Quran
Corpus Quran. Yeah, I like I like that
one too. Yeah.
Yeah. So
reading Oh yeah, it is um reading the
book before the books before you. Mhm.
So it's Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. So
according to the text, what is the
authority on whether or not the Quran is
true? Is it the Quran itself or is it
the previous scriptures? It would be the
previous scriptures in this. Boom. Boom.
So your criteria that what I have is not
the angel because it doesn't line up
with the Quran is outside of the Quran's
criteria. The Quran doesn't say that.
The Quran says that the previous
scriptures are the criteria, not the
Quran itself. So therefore, if if what I
have is doesn't line up with the Quran,
that doesn't make it not the Injeal. It
just means that the Quran is false for
contradicting the Injil. No issue. I
interpret this verse to be a rhetorical
meaning when the Quran uses rhetorical
and figurative language all the time. It
doesn't only It's not rhetorical, bro.
It's I'll explain I'll explain how. If
you are in doubt, the prophet Muhammad
was never in doubt. The understanding of
the is that there uh it goes without
saying that there is no pos probability
of him of his doubting the revelation.
Therefore the propose is to beam the
message to the Muslim community through
uh I think through this address where he
is not the intended recipant. He
literally is not just him but those
listening to him as well as he recites.
You can literally go to like the
crappiest website I think on this
notion. I think they do have like the
same I think the guys from uh I think
it's Quran they have a tap on it brother
I I I am willing to grant you this cuz I
never my argument isn't that Muhammad
doubted that's not my argument the
argument is that the Quran gives a proof
in the case that he doubts or anyone
else reading this anyone listening to
this verse in case that you doubt this
is what you do okay so it's a hypothe
rhetorical, it's a hypothetical. If you
doubt, in the case you doubt, go to the
previous scriptures. And when you do
that, you'll see that the Quran is true.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. What is stopping me
from saying it's referring to the
stories? It doesn't say that. No. What
is stopping me from saying that? It the
verse itself. So the verse specifically
states, so if you are in doubt of what
we have revealed to you, then ask those
who have been reading the book before
you or reading
Good. And what what did he reveal to
him? What was revealed to Muhammad? Uh
Quran. Boom. So it's about the Quran.
And if Muhammad is in doubt about the
Quran, he can go check the previous
scriptures because supposedly the
previous the the Quran is in line with
the previous scriptures. So when he goes
check the previous scriptures, he'll see
the Quran's in line with them and he'll
be like, "Okay, yeah, the Quran is
true." So you are again I think you
didn't allow me to finish this because I
think it was very I sat here quietly.
Hold on. Hold on. No. So like basically
what you did when I said the Quran you
jumped and then like you didn't allow me
to finish afterwards. Oh come on. What
is stopping me from saying the
revelations were particularly referring
to a unqualified sense referring to the
stories because for instance the
stories. Okay. Hold on. Where does the
text say it's referring to things? It
says what we have revealed in general.
Yeah. Revealed. Yeah. Revealed in
general. Repeat that. It just says what
we have revealed to you means so it's
unqualified. So it's not qualified unto
us meaning the Quran. Okay. So the Quran
contains do we agree the Quran contains
stories that are found within other
texts? Sure. Okay. So other texts
contain similar stories about other
prophets like Moses Jesus etc. what they
had the books they had their
revelations. So what is stopping me from
saying that it's referring to generality
of the stories? Let me even grant you
that. Let me grant you that it's the
generality of their stories. If the
Quran is not matching what the previous
scriptures say regarding the stories of
the previous prophets and these people,
their texts, what they have, what they
taught, if it's not in line with that,
then the Quran is false. What do you
what like what story would you be
referring to to make this case? You mean
what? If the Quran The Quran gives
stories on what Jesus taught, right?
Yeah. It gives stories on what Moses
taught, right? Yeah. Yeah. It gives
stories about what David taught,
Abraham, all of them, right?
So when we go check the previous
scriptures and we see wait hold on a
second the Quran's is not matching what
we what I'm reading about Jesus what it
says what he taught how in his stories
and in his teaching or Moses and he's
teaching or Abraham then we can judge
that the we can come to the conclusion
the Quran is false based on the Quran's
own standard okay what I mean by
generality in an unqualified respect
because I you I think the the funny part
about this is this is all with the
presupposition that the the
understanding of the Sahabah and
likewise with everybody around them is
that the Quran does not articulate these
texts are corrupted. The generality can
be referring to the stories not the
specifics. We agree certain doctrines
taught within let's say the New
Testament they do not align with the
Quran on pivotal points. The Quran
doesn't agree with that. The Quran Okay.
Do we agree the Quran contradicts um
let's say uh the idea of high
christologology found within? Of course.
Of course it does. Agree. The Quran but
the Quran. Okay. Sure. You got you the
So yes, we the Quran contradicts that.
But the problem is is that the Quran
doesn't it does not say that this is
what that the Injil contains false
teaching. It doesn't say that it
contains false teaching about Christ or
anything like this. But what it does is
is that it accuses people from deviating
in their ideas and their
interpretations. So it attacks the
interpretation. No, it doesn't. It
doesn't only attack that. We also have
to take hadith into account that we take
the Quran to account. We can take
indicates
the Quran indicates that the text itself
even because it says inah ay 79. So woe
to those who write the hand the books
the book with their own hands and say
and then say this is from Allah to
exchange it for a small price. And then
further on this is wait wait wait wait
stop there. Well to well to those the
Jews which Jews the people of Israel.
Yeah but which ones? The people who are
already on the scripture verse 78 tells
you brother verse 78. I don't have it
pulled up on top of my I don't have it
like pulled up in front of me. Verse 78
talks about how there are those among
them who are illiterate and do not know
the book, but they only follow lies and
conjecture.
And then and then it says, "So woe to
those who write the book with their own
hands, claiming it's from God, seeking a
small price." So contextually, the
people who are writing fake books
claiming that it's from God are people
who don't even know the Torah in the
first place. So with regards to this
point you mentioned the 278 where it
says and among them the among them are
the illiterate who know nothing about
the scripture except lies. So they they
the illiterate who know scripture it's
lies right and then further on if we
read back in 77 it says do they not know
that Allah is aware of what they conceal
and what they reveal. This is with uh
which was referring to the people of any
Israel. No, but which ones though? The
Jews would uh who only know nothing
about lies about the scripture who are
illiterate. Read the verse before that.
Read 76. Oh, you refer to 76. Yeah. 76
says, "When they meet the believers,
they say we believe, but in privately
they say to each other, will you
disclose to the believers that the
knowledge the knowledge Allah has
revealed to you so that they may use it
against you before your Lord." Do you
not understand? Right? So then by the
time we get to verse 77 uh 78 and 79
it's a different group of Jews it's
talking about right 79 78 and 79 it's
not talking about the same group it's
talking about a different group it's 75
to 79 is laying out to you different
parties of the Jews that are doing
different things 78 and 79 we get a
different group of Jews that's doing
something okay 79
right reminds the Jews that he's
omnisient and knows what they try to
conceal as well as what they say or do
openly. So, it makes no difference at
all if the hypocrites try to conceal.
Yeah, I'm I'm we're going there. This is
on verse 76, just for clarification.
Mhm. I'm going to just start over. So,
it would make no difference at all if
the hypocrites tried to conceal their
infidelity from the Muslims or the other
group uh uh not to disclose the verses
of the Torah which speak of the holy
prophet. Yeah. Allah, right? For Allah
himself on has on occasions on different
occasions informed the Muslims in the
Holy Quran as to the hypocrisy of the
Jews and to the testimony of the Torah.
So would you would you agree that
hypocrisy towards the Torah or let let
me switch roles here so that you you
know I can get on that mission here. If
someone is showing hypocrisy towards the
Quran, does that mean that the Quran is
they that they change the Quran? Showing
what do you mean like showing hypocrisy?
like not obeying what the Quran says or
saying that they're gonna obey it but
then they don't. Yeah, that's a clear
point. Okay. Right. But does that mean
that the Quran has changed itself? No,
that's not what I was going to mention
regard What about what about concealing?
What if people try to conceal some of
the things that the Quran says? Like
they they're telling you about the
Quran, but they Huh. It would make no
difference. Correct. Because the Quran
would still not be changed, right? Yeah.
What is that? Why is that relevant?
because it's relevant because you came
here to say that the text is being
corrupted according to the Quran. saying
I'm saying given hey I'm trying to like
you haven't allowed me to finish the
then the it says with 77 deals with the
educated ones among the Jews and 78
speaks of those who are unlettered these
so who are the ones writing I'm getting
there so I'm going to further
clarification these men had no knowledge
of the Torah and they were deficient in
their understanding then the Jewish
scholars did not give them correct or
proper information about the religion
and then I think this is like no wonder
their minds were stuffed with only like
superstitions and like things like that.
But and I think in 79 79 particularly
first off announces the punishment and
the grievous punishment for these two
cents. And it turns to the Jewish
scholars. I think the distinction I'm
going to get there 79. You can see it's
saying so woe to those who distort. Say
it's it draws a distinction between
actually the word is the word isn't
distort. It's the it's right not
distort. So those Yeah, sure. We can you
can translate it as right or distort.
No,
again the meaning word is literally not
distort. Bro, I can I can I can
articulate how this would still make
sense. Even if we translate I don't care
about how you articulate if if you try
to throw in distort to try to make it
fit, it doesn't work cuz that's not what
it says. Articulate better if you're
like so woe to those who write the book
with their own hands. Then they say this
is uh from Allah to barter with it a
price a little. So woe to them for what
they have written with their hands and
woe to them for what they have they
earn. So in the previous verse can we
establish in the previous verse is
referring to illiterate people. People
who don't know the scripture it's un
it's I think they're like it's referring
to unletter ones. It clarifies what it
means by that. People who don't know the
book. Does it does it does the word not
dishante till illiterate or unlettered?
Yes. But in in the context unletter can
it can either mean you know obviously
like literally unlettered. You don't
know how to read or write or that you're
ignorant of that you're ignorant. You're
not you're not educated. And so in this
in this verse it says among those are
unlettered ones who do not know the
book. So you'll grant me that this verse
can actually refer to people who are
just ignorant of the scripture. Yes.
Okay. And then you're saying in 278 279
these are referring to the same group.
Yes. Okay. So they can be ignorant. And
then it says so woe to those who write.
These are the same people. So they're
writing. Do we agree that they're write
they wrote stuff down the book with
their own hands or with their hands?
Yeah. So they are in fact writing with
their hands from scripture. They're not
writing from scripture. They're writing
what they themselves claim. Let's say
they claim scripture. Yes. Okay. So,
it's not scripture, right? Oh, no. I'm
going to I'm going to explain this. No.
No. There's nothing. I've been letting
you go. I've been letting you go for a
very long time, and you're not getting
us anywhere. Let's get straight to it.
According to the verse, are they writing
scripture or are they making stuff up?
I'm making stuff up. Very good. So, the
Torah is just fine. What they're writing
has nothing to do with No, no, no. This
I was worried about what you're going to
do again. So, if if I wrote a book with
Hold on. If I wrote a book with my own
hands and I claim it's from Allah, does
that mean that the Quran's been changed
all of a sudden? No. Oh, so if people
are writing books with their own hands,
claiming it's from Allah, does that mean
that the Torah has been changed? This is
a false equivalency. I disagree with
this proposition you tried to establish.
I'll ask it again. If people are writing
fake books a fall, if they're writing
books that they wrote themselves and
they claim it's from Allah and then
selling they're selling it, does this
mean that the Torah has been changed?
the Torah has not been changed on that
merit alone. However, you establish
something that's facious. You mean
you're trying to draw equivalency
between, let's say, you saying the
Quran, you write something down and
claim to be the Quran and saying that
it's from God. This is not equivalent.
It's not equivalent. Look, I'm going to
say this, man. Uh you're welcome to come
back anytime. I do have other guests.
Let's let's finish this. Please come
back. I'm I'll be live again Wednesday.
Come back. Let's finish this. I do got
to give everybody else a chance though.
Okay. Yeah, sure. But I'll be live same
time. You're more than welcome. I
definitely I enjoyed this dialogue. I
did. All right. No. All right. Take
care, bro. Peace out.